now Russia is creating a naval base in a
breakaway region of Georgia on the Black
Sea Coast that is according to the
separatist leader there who has spoken
to Russian media Moscow recognized
abazia as an independent state after
fighting a war with Georgia in 2008 the
Region's self- style President says he
signed a deal for Russia to have a
permanent base there this comes as
Ukraine expands attacks on Russian
controlled Crimea kees Target last month
in included the Black Sea Fleet command
headquarters in sevastopol let's get
more on this from Julia shapovalova
who's in Moscow for us what more can you
tell us Julia about this new base in
abasia well actually this new base will
appear in oam Chira Bay in abazia which
Russia as you pointed out hasn't
considered part of Georgia since 2008
according to president of abazia as
bjania the agreement has already been
signed between Russia and abazia and he
said that in the near future there would
be a permanent base for the Navy in the
uro region so according to him that will
increase the defense capability of both
Russia and abazia uh also added that a
lot has already been done in the field
of military cooperation between the two
countries but um basically both
countries still have to take more steps
and we know that a number of Personnel
is to be trained there for that uh
Russia currently uh does have permanent
military bases stationed in abazia and
another Moscow backed region of South
astia and throughout the 2000s Oram
Chira Bay was used for the joint
deployment of Civilian ships and
Military boats of both Russian and
aasian navy and in January 2008 uh the
base was transferred to Russia and now
uh there are Patrol ships and Coast
Guard Bo boats um belong belong that
belong to the FSB border Ser is there
Ser as there and Julia what has the
Kremlin actually said about these
developments well it's interesting the
Kremlin has not commented on reports
about the alleged transfer of the Black
Sea Fleet from the city of sevastopol in
Crimea to Russia's uh Novis for instance
um as the question that that was the
question or to abazia uh Kremlin
spokesperson said that uh the issues of
the deployment of of the ships are
totally on the Russian Ministry of
defense and it's quite obvious as this
information is considered sensitive and
classified and the ministry of defense
is highly unlikely to comment on that
either especially in the conditions of
the armed conflict in Ukraine and
obviously you mention it to Ukraine last
month stru the headquarters of Russia's
Black Sea Fleet in the Crimean city of
Copo and it was considered a major blow
for Moscow so of course we're following
all the devel ments here thank you for
that Julia shal overa there for us in
Moscow